make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
since you all really seem to like the
return of how to kill superheroes I
figured we go ahead and throw up another
installment in that series and today
we're gonna figure out the best way to
kill carnage but before we do that we're
going to look into the origin and powers
of its character to see why killing him
is actually a lot harder than it seems
so carnage was created by David
michaleen II and Mark Bagley and first
appeared in the amazing spider-man
number 361 in 1992 now the carnage
symbiote is the first offspring of the
Venom symbiote which we first see when
Eddie Brock who was the host of the
Venom symbiote is incarcerated at Rikers
Island and his cellmate is a man named
Cletus Kasady a convicted serial killer
now Brock had been temporarily separated
from the Venom symbiote but it found him
inside the cell and then rebounded with
him which allowed him to escape what
Brock didn't know was that the symbian
had left behind an offspring in the cell
which bonded to Cletus Kasady now once
bonded to the symbiote Cassidy became
the super villain known as carnage
escaped from the prison and then went on
a killing spree and would be a frequent
antagonist of both spider-man and venom
now while Cletus Kasady is the first and
most frequent host of the carnage
symbiote it has bonded to multiple other
hosts at various times in the past most
notably it bonded with Ben Riley who was
operating as spider-man at the time and
took on the symbiote in an attempt to
keep it from killing any more innocent
people
now Raleigh tries to kill the semi at
using microwaves and while this did
force the symbiote to separate from him
it did not succeed in killing it instead
it's found his way back to Cletus Kasady
another notable host of the carnage
symbiote is longtime spider-man nemesis
Norman Osborn who steals it from a
shield facility and then bonds with it
becoming the red goblin now during his
final altercation with the red Goblin
spider-man hits the carnage symbiote
with a gas tank that explodes and
seemingly kills it however some of the
symbiote remains in the body of Norman
Osborn's grandson Normie and most
recently we saw the corn symbiote bond
with Eddie Brock during the events of
absolute carnage and the subsequent
venom Island story arc and so moving on
to powers the carnage symbiote grants
its host a variety of powers first and
foremost it greatly enhances the
physical strength and durability of its
host and in the case of Cletus Kasady
because he and the Simeon share a bond
that's more complete than venom and
Eddie Brock did his strength is made
even greater by the carnage symbiote
than Eddie Brock strength
by the Venom symbiote and so he is able
to change his shape which he uses to
make organic weapons from the symbiote
that are literally part of his body
these weapons have taken a variety of
forms including swords and axes as well
as projectile weapons such as Spears and
darts and have even taken the form of
tendrils that can invade the mind of
others and control their thoughts he can
also change the appearance of the
symbiote to camouflage himself as well
as alter his size now because the
carnage symbiote is an offspring of the
Venom symbiote itself that inherited all
the powers of spider-man when it was
bonded with Peter Parker carnage has all
those powers as well and so we can crawl
on walls and create web like tendrils to
swing from he also has an ability
similar to Peter Parker's spider sense
which allows him to see in all
directions simultaneously making it
difficult to take him by surprise and is
furthermore undetectable by spider-man's
spider-sense now in addition to the fact
that his powers will allow him to kill
most any body that would think of
attacking him instantly
one of the things that makes carnage so
hard to kill is how durable the symbiote
is it survived blast from the Nova force
the explosion of missiles and blast from
Genesis which is a younger version of
apocalypse as well as being attacked by
Doctor Doom
carnage also possesses a regenerative
healing factor that's so powerful they
can regrow lost limbs in a matter of
seconds on one occasion Carnage's head
is actually blown up and the symbiote
simply reconstructs it instantaneously
during the axis event when carnage had
his personality inverted to become a
hero he sacrifices himself by enveloping
a bomb that was powerful enough to wipe
out the entire human race and while we
were led to believe that this was the
end of carnage we know that it's not
actually destroyed since we've seen him
pop back up several times since then in
fact the carnage symbiote was actually
present in Cletus Cassidy's bloodstream
so it could actually regenerate itself
from one drop of cletus's blood and so
as we can see throughout his time in
Marvel Comics every time someone tries
to kill the carnage symbiote even though
there have been several instances where
it was presumed to have been destroyed
it always manages to survive and
reappear sometime down the road so when
we're trying to formulate a way to
permanently rid ourselves of the carnage
symbiote the first question we should
ask is whether the symbiote has any
weaknesses that we can exploit
traditionally the race of symbionts that
carnage belongs to have a few weaknesses
that have always affected them one of
those weaknesses is a vulnerability to
sonic attacks which have been shown to
have Dennis
affects on most symbionts particularly
Venom I mean who could forget the iconic
scene the bell tower in the beloved hit
film spider-man 3 right but there have
been instances where Sonic's have been
shown to have a limited effect on
carnage but after he was exposed to the
dark hold a book containing knowledge of
dark magic these weaknesses seem to have
completely disappeared so that's
probably not the best route for us to
take another weakness that we could
exploit is fire which has proven to be
extremely effective against symbionts
again though carnage has proven less
susceptible to fire than other symbionts
as I mentioned earlier the Soviets
somehow survived the gas tank explosion
and he's taken blast from Sun fire
without being seriously harmed now there
have certainly been instances where fire
has been shown to cause carnage pain but
I don't think that this weakness is
enough to make it life-threatening but
don't worry Rob core all hope is not
lost one thing that we had been shown to
significantly damage the symbiote is
microwave radiation in fact during a
battle with Firestar that she could have
killed carnage if she had not
voluntarily stopped short of doing so we
also see this vulnerability come into
play when bin Riley uses microwaves to
separate himself from the symbian and so
perhaps we can generate enough microwave
radiation to take out the sim yet for
good if that doesn't work the simian has
also shown a vulnerability to some of
the dark magic practiced by the
worshippers of the Elder God C'thun and
was in fact only able to escape from
them because a magic did not affect
Cletus Kasady and so theoretically if a
symbian could have been separated from
cassidy prior to being captured by the
cult of cathode then they could have
been successful in their plan to
sacrifice it and I think that one of
those methods or perhaps both of them
working in tandem is our best way of
killing carnage at this point we could
just throw the symbiote in a microwave
and then have it cursed by cthe own and
then we win I don't know maybe we would
have to use the microwave radiation to
separate the symbian from its host and
then use dark magic to get rid of it
once and for all but let me know what
you guys think right killing carnage is
much much harder than you would
originally think right you would assume
the killing here would be the same way
as killing like venom or somebody like
that not so he's just in exceedingly
like durable character but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here -
comments explain - make sure you guys
the sub button to become part of the rod
4 if you guys enjoy this video make sure
you drop a like
and I will catch you all later
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]